This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6 Minute English from the BBC
Hello and welcome to 6 Minute English.
I'm Neil and joining me today is Dan,
who's weighed down with shopping bags and wearing something very...
Well, strange.
What's going on, Dan?
Well, I was feeling a bit miserable,
so I decided to cheer myself up by going shopping.
Well, that's lucky because the link between shopping and mood
is what we're looking at in this 6 Minute English.
And of course, we'll be giving you 6
mood and shopping-related vocabulary items.
But first, our quiz.
Online shoppers in which country spend more per household
than consumers in any other country,
according to a report by the UK Cards Association.
Is it A, the USA, B, Norway or C the UK?
Hmm. Norway seems to come top of lots of our lists.
So for that reason alone, I'm going to say Norway.
Well, okay. We'll find out at the end of the show.
Now, Dan, you said just now that you went shopping
because you were feeling down.
That's right.
I like a bit of retail therapy.
Retail therapy is a humorous expression,
which means going shopping to make yourself feel better.
Oh, I do that all the time.
Yes, I can see.
And you're not alone.
According to some research done by the website
MoneySupermarket.com,
people are more likely to buy things
though later regret when they're feeling sad,
bored or stressed.
Well, I was feeling a bit down in the dumps.
And that's a way of saying sad.
Oh, dear, Dan.
Sorry to hear you've been down in the dumps.
I only hope you don't get a pang of regret
about your purchases when you get them home.
The research suggests that you will.
A pang is a sharp pain.
We often hear it used figuratively
to talk about strong emotions like guilt, regret,
and remorse.
And you're making me feel worse, Neil.
Sorry, Dan.
It's all for educational purposes.
Our audience will learn from your pain.
Remorse is like regret.
And there's a good expression to describe exactly
that bad feeling you get when you realize
you don't really need or want the things
that you've bought.
Buyer's remorse.
OK, OK, OK.
Enough about me.
Let's hear from Sam, Phil, and Catherine
from the Learning English team
to see if their mood affects the shopping choices they make.
Listen carefully.
Can you hear the three types of things they say
that they buy when they're down in the dumps?
Honestly, I tend to buy food.
I anything that will bring me comfort.
So it can be any sort of warm drink, hot drink,
but also anything warm and cozy, so like a nice jumper.
Definitely if I've had a bad day at work
or for whatever reason, I feel terrible tired.
I am more likely to buy something on the way home.
Oh, when I'm feeling sad, I probably buy a little bit of wine
and often something to wear.
I find that a bit of retail therapy when I'm sad.
Usually does the trick at the time,
so it makes me feel better,
but I do find that when I look at my wardrobe,
the things that I bought when I was sad, I never wear them.
Sam, Phil, and Catherine there from the BBC Learning English team
talking about what kind of things they buy when they're feeling down.
What were they?
Food, drink, and clothes.
Yes, that's right.
Sam mentioned she buys food, warm drinks, and a nice jumper
to keep her cozy.
That's the feeling of being warm, comfortable and relaxed.
Catherine also mentioned drinks this time wine,
and she also said that buying clothes does the trick.
That means achieves the result she intended.
But what's interesting is that Catherine said she never wears the clothes she buys
when she's feeling sad.
That's exactly what the survey found.
People regret the purchases they make when they're sad,
bored or stressed.
Hmm, sounds like a case of buyer's remorse.
It does indeed.
Well, time now for the answer to our quiz question.
I asked this.
Online shoppers in which country spend more per household
than consumers in any other country,
according to a report from the UK Cards Association.
Is it A, the USA, B, Norway, and C the UK?
And I said B, Norway.
And I'm afraid you might need to go and buy some more stuff to cheer you up.
You're wrong.
The correct answer is the UK.
Apparently, UK households spent the equivalent of
4,611 pounds.
That's almost $6,000 using payment cards online in 2015.
Well, I hope they were happy when they made those purchases
or they may feel the pang of regret.
I'm scared I might get after today's discussion.
Well, a good recap of the vocabulary from this program might do the trick.
Shall we start with the first word?
Do you ever go in for a bit of retail therapy, Neil?
Actually, I try to avoid it, especially after reading this survey.
I don't think the happiness you feel after buying something last very long.
In fact, you can end up feeling down in the dumps.
Yes, down in the dumps, meaning sad or unhappy.
And a pang of regret might follow once you realize you spend a lot of money on something
you don't really need.
A pang is a stab used here figuratively to mean a sharp pain.
Used to talk about strong emotions.
And after that pang can come buyers remorse.
I'm beginning to feel buyers remorse from this leopard skin onesie.
It seemed like such a good idea at the time.
It does look cosy at least.
That's warm, comfortable and relaxed.
So I think if that's what you wanted, it does the trick.
Does the trick, meaning achieves the results you wanted?
Please remember to check out our Facebook, Twitter and YouTube pages.
Bye-bye.
Goodbye.
6-Mate English.
From BBCLearningEnglish.com.